قال ايهود باراك رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
السابق ان الجيش الاسرائيلي حقق انجازات
مهمه في قطاع غزه لكنه بعيد عن تحقيق
اهداف الحرب واضاف باراك ان احداث السابع
من اكتوبر كانت الاخطر في تاريخ اسرائيل
وانها انطوت على اذلال وعدم كفاءه وخلل في
اجهزه الدوله وقال باراك ان من يعتقد انه
بالامكان حث الفلسطينيين في غزه على
الهجره الطوعيه او الترانسفير فهو يحلم
احلى ما
يقضه من جهته قال وزير الدفاع الاصالي
يواف جالاند ان تركيز عمليات الجيش
الاصالي ينصب حاليا على خان يونس في جنوب
قطاع
غزه انا ممتن واقدر جدا عمليات سلاح الجو
والمقاتلين في الجو وفي البر والتعاون
بينهما ومن المفضل ان يطغى هدير الطائرات
على الاقوال التي لا فائده منها لتمكين
الجيش من القيام بمهامه بهدوء وامان ونحن
في عمليات كبيره في قطاع غزه وستتواصل
فتره طويله حتى تحقيق الاهداف وهي تتركز
حاليا في خان يونس والانجازات هناك مثيره
ومحدده والاهداف
تتحقق